لديك جواز السفر هنا
لينورا ليمكي ، البالغة من العمر تسعة عشر عامًا ، تسحب
جواز سفرها الألماني
، كانت في الخامسة عشرة من عمرها عندما غادرت المنزل الآن
عالقة في شمال سوريا
مع طفلين ، والدهما أحد أفراد
داعش ،
تنتظرها تكافح لتذكر آخر
مرة استحممت فيها
لقد عدت إلى الوراء قبل شهر أو أكثر ، ثم
تتذكر اليوم الذي أنجبت فيه
أصغر ماريا
قبل 20 يومًا فقط ، لكن بعد ولادتي في
هذا اليوم ، صنعت لي القليل من
الماء الدافئ وكنت أقوم
بتنظيف كل شيء لينورا هو واحد من
مئات داعش  يعتقد أتباع من أوروبا
أنهم موجودون في سوريا ،
لكن دولًا مثل ألمانيا لا
تتسرع في استعادتهم ، قالت وزارة الخارجية الألمانية لشبكة CNN إنها ليس لديها معلومات عن عائلة ليمكي وأن
المساعدة القنصلية كانت
مستحيلة تقريبًا ، قالوا إن
الحكومة الفيدرالية تدرس
الخيارات الممكنة  تمكين
المواطنين الألمان من
مغادرة سوريا خاصة في
الحالات الإنسانية ، نشرت قسد هذه الصورة منذ
اعتقال زوج لينورا مارتن ليمكي
لكنها ليست كذلك.  لم توضح المكان الذي
سيحاكم فيه
في البداية ، فقد أصرت على أنه كان يعمل فقط على إصلاح
أجهزة الكمبيوتر المحمولة لداعش ، ثم
تتساءل بصوت عالٍ ما الذي قادها إلى هنا
وكيف يمكنها إعادة بناتها إلى المنزل
عندما تأكل خبزًا واحدًا لمدة يومين
ولم تستطع ابنك لمدة عام واحد.  تمشي
لأنها كانت تعاني من الجوع الشديد ،
أصبحت ملحوظة لأنه لا توجد
فيتامينات
لا تستطيع كل أم
قبولها ، وأنا أفعل هذا من
أجل الله هنا من أجل إلهي
ولكن عندما يبكي طفلك حقًا
ويتأرجح على الأرض ، فأنت تقول ولكن
أنت مجنون ،
ما علاقة هذا بالإسلام الذي
يحتضن ابنتيها ماريا
وحبيبة لينورا على متن الحافلة رقم 2 على
أمل إقامة قصيرة في مخيم للاجئين ،
فهي ترسل رسالة إلى والدها
باللغة الألمانية ،
وآمل أن أراك قريبًا.  أحبك
ونأمل أن
نكون معًا قريبًا ولكن
رحلة لينورا لم تنته بعد وليس من الواضح ما إذا كانت
ألمانيا ستستقبل منزلها أو متى
ستستقبلها أتيكا شوبرت سي إن برلين